cloud storage costs money and unless
you're made of money you'll want to
understand how to optimize your spending
to match your data storage and serving
needs
as a fellow human who's not made of
money let's talk about those fees
your options and the importance of
budgeting in cloud storage
[Music]
just like a grocery run on an empty
stomach a budget can help you keep your
cloud computing and food bills from
getting
surprising let's look at how pricing
breaks down for cloud storage
to start cloud storage pricing is based
on the following components
data storage which is the amount of data
stored in your buckets
the rates will vary depending on the
storage class of your data
and the location of your buckets
retrieval and early deletion fees
those are applicable for data stored
outside of standard storage classes
and network usage the amount of data
read from
or moving around between your buckets
operations usage are the actions you
take in cloud storage
like listing objects in your buckets
and remember there are four different
storage types
and the less frequently you access that
storage the less you pay to store it
cost for all four is based upon at rest
per location
which is a fun way of saying the cost is
determined by where the data lives when
it's just chilling in storage
and not where it's actually being used
for standard storage the monthly cost is
the only cost you need to plan for
however with the other three storage
types you'll want to consider the
minimum duration of that data
as well as any retrieval costs for
example
cold line storage has a minimum storage
duration of 90 days
and a retrieval cost of say two pennies
so the cheaper monthly cost is
completely worth it if you only want to
access this data about twice a year
if however you find yourself accessing
or updating the data every week
you'll end up spending more money than
if you had selected standard storage to
begin with
when discussing network costs we also
need to distinguish between egress
and ingress egress represents the data
sent from cloud storage
like when reading data and ingress
represents the data sent to cloud
storage
like when writing data network ingress
is
always free for network egress there are
three categories to consider
first when that network egress is moving
or copying data to other cloud storage
buckets
or when other google cloud services
access that data
this is considered network egress within
google cloud and is free within regions
such as reading data in a u.s east one
bucket into a u.s
bigquery data set pricing then applies
for egress between regions
or across continents second if you use
certain google cloud network products
such as cloud cdn or cloud interconnect
egress pricing is based on their pricing
tables
all other egress is considered to be
general network usage and is built based
upon which continent the data is
traveling to
the fourth factor to consider with
billing is operations
operation charges apply when you perform
operations within cloud storage
to clarify an operation is an action
that makes changes to
or retrieves information about buckets
and objects in cloud storage
operations are divided into three
categories class a
class b and free for a full list of the
operations that fall into each class
check the documentation as a brief
overview
class a includes creating storage
buckets and objects
class b includes retrieving storage
objects
and free operations are primarily
deletions
to build your own budget with accurate
cost estimates check out the pricing
calculator
and for more information or to see
specific costs
please be sure to check out the
documentation linked below
having a budget will help you plan as
there's so much more that you can do
with cloud storage but that's all for
another episode
subscribe give us a like and let us know
what features of cloud storage you'd
like to learn more about
thanks for joining us for this quick
bite of cloud storage
[Music]